foreign
is this a rare video right here yes it
is deep canvas was the way to get
painted brush Strokes into 3D space I
don't know if people nowadays understand
how pivotal both shorts and movies were
for technology
I mean these were all animated in Maya
still that wasn't still is Disney's tool
look how tiny his arms are
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around so you can find out
how to get 30 off of break on holiday
bundles
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of animators react I'm Nikon I'm
joined by Alex snow Long Time guest and
a new guest Patrick Osborne I directed
Beast for Disney I was the animation
supervisor on paperman and did another
short for Google called Pearl gotten the
chance to do a lot of really really cool
things decided to talk about some
animation with you guys these guys are
both actually very accomplished and I'm
a little nervous here sitting between
them it's gonna be a really good time so
let's jump in
so you directed paperman that was the
animation supervisor I did the shot uh
3D and 2D John cars who directed this
was an animator Pixar he was gonna make
the short at Pixar way back but ended up
moving down to LA to be the animation
director on Tangled after Tangled he
asked the management if he could maybe
revive the short but not as a 3D thing
as kind of a 2d 3D mix can you talk
about that because the coolest thing
about paperman other than it's like the
best short ever it was kind of the first
step into this new age of CG animation
having more style and kind of taking a
step towards the appeal of 2D animation
it's on once which is weird in 2D
normally don't put the effort in to do
that many in-betweens in that tight and
in betweens and the only reason you can
do that is because we've made software
that kind of assisted with that and made
it a little bit easier how it works is
you can draw Vector lines on top of a
rendered image that rendered image had
pixel accurate motion vectors so it knew
where the 3D animation was moving
throughout the shot so as you you
pressed play that line would assume to
travel with whatever was underneath but
you could also do one drawing paste it
10 frames down fix them and then Auto in
betweens while using the arcs in motion
of the underneath animation
it's really amazing to have software
being developed while you're making the
film because you can come up with an
idea that would make it easier and
sometimes the engineers like that might
be possible today it's just a commitment
to it I mean it really sets the stage
for I mean everyone knows spider-verse
at this point a good point to look at a
good point of reference is like the nose
when you turn you can see the silhouette
of the nose and you would draw that you
can see when it's not cutting the
silhouette it's more of like the nostril
that gets emphasized and then you see
the rest of the nose with the shadow but
it has to calculate when that nose is
turning when to draw the bridge when not
to draw the bridge it's giving you a lot
out of nothing it's doing complex
calculations to understand art it's like
the computer is like I will be an artist
but that's like very similar to what
they did on spiderverse and that's just
like a small example of what is trying
to calculate on these CG animations to
take the first step into kind of
Shifting to the 2D look the tech reminds
me a little bit of what people have been
doing with EBC sense when you make a 3D
animation you can have each pixel give
you the information of how fast the
pixel is moving and where it's going so
you can theoretically pin things to
those pixels EB synth kind of does the
same thing both you know AI predicted
motion vectors for video it gets weird
and smeary I mean you can see it in all
the Joel Haver videos yeah the trick
with doing it at a studio level is the
editability and the fine pixel control
that became the biggest thing to really
focus on that it felt polished and
complete still and there are I still see
errors but like you see errors yeah
whatever
[Music]
how did you achieve the Shadows like on
a close-up you could see like the shadow
is more like a brush it's all hand
painted I feel like hand painting is
great as long as it's not a pain in the
ass to like edit it's like real time
adjusting to you and you can hit play
and watch if it breaks or not it's
really kind of nice to work that way so
the whole tool was fairly real time were
they using like CG shadows as a base and
then painting over them you would draw
the character over a finished render got
it she'd have like a Pixar style render
and you're like time to handify this and
you see you go in it it was flat it was
a little flatter but yeah it was like a
two-tone render kind of you know so you
could you could eye dropper the colors
directly from the red oh cool
[Music]
why haven't we seen a movie come out
with this kind of Technology whoever's
running the studio kind of has this
balance to make against How Art House
how fresh how unique even though this
feels like Disney and classic Disney
it's not necessarily the Disney's of the
last 10 years as soon as you see that
poster or that trailer you need to know
that's a Disney movie and I want to see
it when junk cars came up with doing it
this style and it was partially because
we were there working on Tangled and
Glenn Keane you'd animate a shot and
Glenn Keaton would sit down at your desk
for three hours you might drop redraw an
anime Passat with you having that vibe
in the studio I think we were kind of
feeling like we don't want to forget
this stuff could we do a high-tech
version of it and that is kind of
inspired if you play the pet one this
was on LA Times this is how I could
actually like even show it is this a
rare video right here yes it is this
combined with the feeling of 2D needs to
come back in some way and John having
the short paper man kind of ready to go
and written those things lighted at the
same time to make the Meander tool
possible also Meander the paper Man
drawing tool was initially an effects
tool and it was meant to Auto in between
really complex effects drawings so I'm
going to do like smoke and fire and yeah
there's things that are really tedious
to draw you could take a drawing and
another drawing and then you could draw
an arc that represented the timing so in
between but it wouldn't do it
mechanically so this is all Maya
viewport just coloring objects and then
painting over a little bit oh really
viewport render viewport render are you
painting over every single frame by hand
yeah for the smears and stuff or like
that end image that's
great so they're just like really good
texture work in 3D modeling it's just
polys
man I feel like a big barrier to
animation it's just how time consuming
it is where are we on that spectrum of
like where animation is super accessible
anybody can do it and like make a movie
or it was you know 50 years ago 100
years ago where you have to draw every
single frame by hand on paper I think
we're like 20 years behind the k camera
Revolution you know the uh beautiful
high quality cameras came down in
accessibility so like the actual vision
and hand of the artist is a little more
like right there in the front and I
think animation tools with EV and unreal
and unity are making it come down to
that level where it's a little more
sandboxy they're all still pretty techy
I think you still do need like that four
or five years of like ramp into it with
a specialty where you become a model or
an animator or whatever but once you've
got like that Foundation that the tool
sets are really fun now our industry
changes every 25 30 years massively and
everyone just has to know what's going
to happen and like push forward anytime
I'm working with like a new tool or
technique what's the thing that it gives
you for free right with a 3D program
changing perspectives is free it's just
you learn to move the camera and it's
fine but you know rendering is not
necessarily free on the flip side if
you're dealing with like paint and
pencils rendering it is literally free
like you put the paint on the paper boom
it's right there like you don't need to
render it it just instantly happens in
front of you but of course changing a
perspective on a drawing well now you
have to redraw the whole drawing
whatever medium you step into you the
more you can leverage the tools so like
whatever they give you for free take all
of that yeah and like use as much of
that as possible and this is making the
complex more simple more achievable let
me put the old mill on because like this
idea of pushing technology has always
been at the core of why Studios make
shorts
[Music]
37 it says old in the title now this is
like gorgeous and full of color so
what's special about this short film
Network well it is the beginning of the
legacy of using the short format to do
something that pushes look and
Technology more of what they're getting
out of it is learning and this was one
of the earliest you know putting color
and sound in multi-plane camera together
that let them know that they could go
and make Snow White I don't know if
people nowadays understand how pivotal
both shorts and movies were for
technology like Pixar all those great
ones you know like Nemo you go we've
never gone under the water for a movie
it's like oh first exactly there's a
reason Beyond just creativity technology
has been such a driving force especially
in CG but even in 2D people forget like
you didn't have a multi-plane camera you
couldn't have things on different layers
I mean animation is already so
complicated like putting the sheet down
and not having it a little bit to the
right or left with a little little pegs
that are just made of paper and now you
have a multi-plane camera with like
seven layers that you're doing this for
it's planes of glass on a literal shelf
that the camera's shooting through it's
like 15 feet tall there's always
pictures of like a dude smoking a
cigarette like yeah he's working on it
yeah
Indiana Jones oh I got one right fit a
little deus ex machina right there yeah
I don't know it was the animation at the
time anywhere at this quality or is this
like an exception this is a huge
exception how is this animation
different from other stuff that was
coming out around it like look at that
it's good it's good this was like
equivalent to the Pixar boom of like
entering CG and and you start asking the
questions how do you do that thing how
do you build build build build build
this is much more distance to music too
and I believe it was a big deal like
think about doing that water effects
even now like I don't actually know how
to do that I don't know that's a good
question
are they moving something in his
Rippling I feel like it might actually
be I think it might actually be like a
glass or something yeah like glass with
water on it or like like a Ripple Glass
that you move yeah yeah that makes more
sense I mean I do love like that a lot
of Animation at this time really felt
like a magic trick one of my like weird
internal goals when I make something is
like if I show this to Alex or Nico or
anyone who does know and it can still be
a magic trick yeah I'll be happy with
myself yeah that's a good trick one of
Disney's kind of amazing secret weapons
this guy named Eric Daniels who worked
on deep canvas for Tarzan the Deep
canvas was the way to get painted brush
Strokes into 3D space that was one of
the earlier paint Strokes in 3D space
you know yeah the things that I always
thought was like pretty dang cool I have
no idea where in Tarzan it is though
anytime
yeah
any tunnel yeah yeah this one you can
start to feel it with my 2022i it shows
itself yeah right but even still only a
little I mean and when you're not
looking for it if you're looking at a
Tarzan you just go yeah that was cool
I mean the integration is so cool I mean
this is kind of similar to what blender
is you can do it now yeah yeah I love
that like every artist kind of has this
now you could grease pencil it yeah and
sort of do it how are they getting the
textures on there the way I understand
it from Eric Daniels you had the 3D as
reference and you did a painting over it
every so many frames and every brush
stroke was remembered and it was created
as a polygon and kind of like glued onto
the stuff sort of manually there were no
like cintiques or anything yet so it was
like a graphics tablet like an intuos
tablet kind of and then of course Glenn
Keane's incredible animation over top of
everything doesn't hurt because that's
what you're looking at you know yeah and
we can I guess we can go to Feast now
and then I can talk about getting to
there
how does this evolve from paperman what
were the big changes or what were the
big things you ran into there's very
little line work in this but there is
neanderline work over the dog a lot of
the times and we could draw over the
frames just like in paperman not a lot
of moving cameras which makes things
like that a lot easier it was really the
VFX soup Josh stob on this that really
kind of made it really work as a
cohesive thing looking at Charlie's
paintings a simple like tune look but
not tune shade I hate toon shade why do
you hate Tunes it creates too much
detail so if you look at the dark and
light lighting on Winston when he's lit
the lighting on him is rendered but then
changed so we made it so you could alter
the dark and the light divide so it
wasn't giving you too much of that 3D
detail a lot of the times the nose is
shaded complicated and gets all into
nooks and crannies on a 3D model and we
want it to be clean so you guys
developed a tech for that or yeah it's
uh it was a similar to paper man but as
a way to kind of glue on nuke masks on
top of 3D models that would track with
it sometimes you want to look like light
a little bit but not be literal light
I like also like his beard is just a
texture and then a few hairs the trick
with things like that is when line
weight and line quality isn't considered
from the camera's point of view so you
never want to see a line as it wraps
around get thin like it's projected onto
paper and these are all camera facing
polys or vectors rendered at the end so
it's one of the other I think it's kind
of a mix here if you have your digital
lines in the shot like this character
here this beard let's say you got up and
walked away from us you wouldn't want
those lines to get thinner as if the
artist is using sharper ingredients
pencils the farther away he gets you
want to stay the same way yeah it gives
you the gives away the trick and
dimensional things like that are the
hardest you really want a level of
detail thing where things are
disappearing or redrawing differently if
it's really smooth you'll notice it so
when you animate stuff like that you
want to have like moments of hits that
you can disguise the swap out of
anything that you're doing like that I
mean even if you look at his Lids it's
like you're designing for the shot and
the camera angle like when his eyelids
are closed they're not just two flat
lines you know you curve them depending
on the attitude the emotion in the angle
of the head
how are you doing the edge work like the
edges on this other than inside out I
don't know if I've ever seen this
accomplished successfully in CG and
inside out it does it with basically a
fuzzy texture which this is not that
this is way easier than that this is a
paper man had the same it was a noise
field like a it looked like TV noise if
you paused it but that noise field was
fading between a few other noise
patterns every eight frames or so and
then the motion vectors of the character
smear it but if you hit play and just
watch the noise pattern you can see the
animation in it like a Magic Eye and
that's used to mask the edges of the
character and nuke you bleed the
characters outward you bloom them a
little bit and then you layer it back on
top of itself or on top of the
background with the noise mask
foreign
still that wasn't still is Disney's tool
My Philosophy On Tools now is like like
do what the computer is good at for
whatever's good like you're saying have
it try to do what the artist would do
but make it easily fixable I'm a Total
Blender person now really yeah I'm just
a fan of live development with a big
feature you get to like lock things in
and things can't break and you want to
make sure that you're consistent but a
lot of what I'm doing is like doing
tests to pitch movies and TV shows and I
need to be flexible but also be able to
do that with whatever tool is at hand
and Leonard just has a lot of that you
know last year I did right the only live
action thing I've ever done which was a
concert film with Billy eilish and I
pre-vis the entire thing in blender
because I was like I want to know where
to tell the guys to put the camera right
you guys know how copyright music is on
YouTube you want to learn more about
this also a mind-blowing fact about that
That's all folks Porky Pig ending and
the Hollywood Bowl check it out this
episode extended on our website quarter
digital.com so we're looking at all
these like examples of like artists
spending months in like passion and
skill we have won another spectrum and
now we're gonna go to the other end of
the spectrum because it's educational
it's good to critique things it helps us
figure out how to be better so let's
take a look at Bratz Rock angels part
five
let's see some Batman the Animated
Series inspired background yep wow it's
like a video game Shader you know you
talk about the appeal of characters and
you really I really feel like Bratz has
like defined the peak of character
appeal hi hi I'm missing something
the dialogue is if you haven't seen this
clip the dialogue is equally as
fantastic it's in London you can tell
because there's oh okay they're doing
like an Akira slide yeah what's a little
bit shocking is that opening that
opening environment it's almost great I
mean I don't know where in the world has
these Gothic shadowy Towers it's London
there's a red Phone Booth it tells you
right there I mean there's no
deformation on their faces either like
their eyes and stuff move along the
model but there's no wrinkles created
when you like raise your eyebrow there's
no volumetric change so it's like
eyebrows are just like textures yeah and
like the British flag is like weirdly
projected on the whole helmet kind of
wraparound style so it doesn't really
yeah I mean definitely they just Google
image the flag and put it on I'd like
you know transition up to the Moon
that's well that's how this thing oh
yeah a little Artistry with some
ambition there guys I've had an
over-the-top emotional breakthrough yeah
I love the dudes I love the dudes like
1997 boy band haircut
the hair is like actually sometimes it's
simulated it looks like yeah I mean
everything's moving pose to pose which
is fine but the computer is doing more
than the animator here so the anime is
just like hitting one pose jump forward
two seconds hitting a second post yeah
it's like yeah and then maybe like one
in between on where it needs to like if
the arm freaks out they're connecting it
but things are just kind of moving and
holding or holding with a little bit of
change into the next pose these jobs
exist companies want to make stuff like
this yeah and if you're learning it's
better to learn while someone pays you
and get used to a pipeline hopefully it
pays okay you know and I think yeah
getting used to like actually hitting
poses on a character and delivering
something and on a schedule which is
probably like 30 40 minutes it's very I
imagine the schedule is insanely fast
yeah animation takes time to polish and
it all starts looking like this this is
like what layout kind of looks like in
some ways and then you just spend more
time making it better until they take it
away from you there's so much to learn
to be able to just animate anything even
poorly that you get obsessed with
getting better at that getting as good
as the movies you see you don't realize
that that's one aspect of the job
there's so much more to working for
somebody than working on your own in
your own time it's like there's
deadlines there's opinions there's a
workflow you have to develop where you
can change things when you get notes so
that you're not just like there it is
and you're like okay what if you move
this little thing you're like that'll
blow everything up because that's not a
good place to be and so I mean it's
going to happen regardless so someone
messaged me the other day with all these
like finished projects not getting
released yeah and them saying like I'd
put myself into all this stuff I take
this so personally how do you continue
to be passionate and make good work when
this kind of stuff can happen and I'm
like you have to enjoy what you're doing
during the day and not make your you
know job satisfaction be a part of the
release or the reception right of what
other people think you only have control
about how serious and how much effort
you put into the actual stuff you're
doing day to day and uh kind of have to
be kind of stoic about I can't control
that other stuff so yeah it can't be why
you do the work right it can't be a part
of what makes you more about your own
growth or experience because if you're
learning you can join this I think it's
awesome like yeah and and use that as a
stepping stone to do better stuff later
also that's an achievement as much as we
can rag on it like that is an
achievement yeah who knows how many
animators were on that and what they had
to deliver if you told a Disney animator
to make as much footage as they probably
have to do I don't know how different it
would look also these big studios you
have libraries of poses that have been
looked at designed you have a better
starting point if you're given a rig
that barely works and no prep work
because you just have to go it's harder
to get to the point they're getting to
it's a much different process to elevate
what's already there where a lot of the
decisions are made than it is to be
given a shot where you go she's looking
at the computer figure it out it's 10
minutes long and you're like what these
two sequences together is the size of
feast and almost nothing happens from
what I can tell
figure it out yeah it's a feat to make
anything and finish it so there's always
that you know I do like the tiniest arms
are
sorry
it's like a baby now at the end of the
film cast episodes of the review movies
they always end it with and so and so
that whatever director made a film and
that's pretty amazing yeah there you go
regardless of what we think if you guys
have any stop motion or experimental
animation suggestions shout it out let
us know and take a look hey guys I'm
Jordan and I'm here to talk to you about
our sponsor today raycon my favorite
thing about wireless earbuds first and
foremost is the fact that I can work out
in them and they don't have a wire
that's getting me all tangled up and
they have a super long battery life and
if I feel like they're going to be dying
soon I can just pop them right back into
a rechargeable case raycons comes in an
array of different colors and they can
match your own personal style also you
know the holidays are coming up so if
you're looking for a great gift to give
someone great cons are definitely the
way to go not only can you choose the
everyday buds but they also have the
fitness earbuds as well and check this
out the everyday headphones we're all
working on a tight budget but if you
click the link in the description box I
go to buyraycon.com quartered crew you
can get 20 off or save even bigger and
get 30 percent off raycons exclusive
holiday bundles all right well I have
more work to do so I'm gonna put on my
earbuds and go jam out at my desk but
you guys continue animators react and
have an amazing holidays
thank you so much for watching guys
thank you so much for joining us Alex
and Patrick these guys didn't want to
promote anything so I'm going to have
them tell you to watch another movie
Patrick uh there's a short on YouTube
called Mall stories by Elizabeth Ito and
it's wonderful and sweet and she's
amazing so go check that out how about
you Alex I literally was gonna say Mall
stories what really oh yeah come on no I
got I screened it at the mall here and I
was just talking about it yesterday
about chromosphere Studios and mall
stores so double watch that movie cool
enjoy them all stories and consider
subscribing I'm not going to promote our
stuff just go watch them all stories
good luck